こんにちははじめ社長ですお前たち子供の川山ぐるじむそう僕の小学校の時の唯一の
友達嘘ですよそうですよ松井ましたけどもジャングルジムでめちゃくちゃ遊んでたん
ですね小学校行っ分かるでしょうーどぅちょっます
して俺の家に再現しようと思います相当になるとなんかいうふうに魅力を感じるわけ
ですよ
なんで今日あの今日はこちらに割り箸戦前準備したのでこの我々戦前をつくって車ん
ぐるじ民具を作ってみようと思います
戦前もあるともコンビニでを走りませんって普通に言います線全13ことって言ってる
んだから見たことねえボテ前とかそう
どれだけの木が伐採されたことかちゃんとあの山黒ずみ作った後もちゃんと食べます
からねこのをはせ使って資源を大事にしあうねみんなじゃあもつべこべ言わずに
とっととザイグルチームを作りましょう話はそれからだ
かもよ際キャラ作っていきましょうこういう数でですね ok や取り集め茶を作り
ますそれずに行けます強度を大事にしていきたいとおもいます
妻の反映決めてなかったですけれどもなる二
ちょっとまだ範囲を決めてなかったんですけどもなるべく大きいのを作ってみようと
思います
とりあえずこんなもんで1回にちょっと立ててみましょう
を戦ったらも失敗ですかねこれ何とかいけそう
なんとかたつえーこちらお姉さまねーいけそうですね言えそうなんですけどもうたぶん
これねー
相当時間かかるね tetsuya 山町
[音楽]
これは世にも有名な僕を見ながらですね
すごい人生本宮市だって一体なんなんとソーダで敵が攻めてきた時で
踊りやぐらからスプーンを火で適度好機を防ぐだよ
ええええ
五井先生そうなのでそうだよ
次のチェストに出るからしっかり覚えるだよ
曲がって設定を飛び櫓
はーい
逆だろ
[音楽]
3時間かかっております3次元でやっとプロレベルです
はいて利害関係しました詰まってもうもう限界
[音楽]
me
ん n ame
ani
[音楽]
はいプーレ製作時間約4時間ぐらいですね全然まだまで生きたんですけどもうちょっと
下の方の強度が台風やられてだいぶ傾いてきています結構固めちゃってるんですけど
もうまあやう
すぎ締めの用かな裾が住んでみましょう
[音楽]
[拍手]
def